Hi,
this is the first of a 12 part series of short videos based on my new
book beyond order 12 more rules for life.
Each video features one of the rules as well as a paragraph from the
chapter. Based on that rule
rule one do not carelessly denigrate,
social institutions or creative achievement.
This paragraph is from a section entitled.
What should we point to it is worth considering deeply just how
necessity limits the universe of viable solutions and implementable
plans. First,
a plan must in principle solve some genuine problem.
Second,
it must appeal to others often in the face of competing plans or those
others will not cooperate and might well object.
If I value something,
therefore I must determine how to value it so that others
potentially benefit. It cannot just be good for me.
It must be good for me and the people around me and even that is not enough,
which means that there are even more constraints on how the world must be
perceived and acted upon the manner in which I view and value the world.
Integrity associated with the plans I am making has to work for me,
my family, and the broader community. Furthermore,
it needs to work today in a manner that does not make a worst house of tomorrow
next week, next month. And next year, even the next decade or century
a good solution to an important problem must be repeatable without
deterioration across repetitions,
Iterable in a word across people. And across time,
these universal constraints manifest biologically and imposed
socially reduce the complexity of the world to something approximating a
universally understandable domain of value.
This is exceptionally important.
Although there are an unlimited number of problems,
as well as an unlimited number of potential solutions.
There are a comparatively limited number of solutions that work practically,
psychologically and socially simultaneously
the fact of limited solutions implies the existence of something like a natural
ethic. Variable, perhaps as human languages are variable,
but still characterized by something solid and universally recognizable at
its base.
It is the reality of this natural ethic that makes thoughtless denigration of
social institutions, both wrong and dangerous, wrong,
and dangerous because those institutions have evolved to solve problems.
That must be solved for life to continue.
They are by no means perfect,
but making them better rather than worse is a tricky problem. Indeed.
And order will be available in print and audio format March 2nd, 2021,
but can be pre-ordered before that details can be
found@jordanbpeterson.com.
A more precise URL can be found in the description of this video.